[Music]
good afternoon my Scotia as you know
parole and a privilege it's a mistake
but it happened and if I were to be
released I would um I would just want
the simple life I just wanna hold on a
job make some friends you know pay my
bills even if this was awesome
it made 20 people seven people why do
you need to do this because it's what
I'm gonna how long would it take you to
make sent a pieces of jewelry if I were
a parent how long if I told you didn't
have to look at your mother anymore its
need the water first point what do you
need
which man named Walt which real name
eight-ball what is we could make all
this go away then purrs as well sorry
okay with my family I told you coming in
garage let me tell you how big a job
nose job I'll be back before you know
with him this is mommy's very special
work trip
three and a half weeks the met will be
hosting its annual ball we are going to
Robyn's not the ball itself the neck of
Daphne Kluger valued at over a hundred
million dollars revenge it's a twofer do
not want a job in a job
can't we just go to this do we have to
steal stuff yes is it genetic or the
whole family like this better
[Music]
you